effectivement en tout cas on peut voir à
partir de ces premiers résultats que
c'est de la majorité sénatoriale va très
certainement être conforté voire
peut-être même renforcé et qu'il n'y
aura pas de vague ni même de ressac ni
même de flux en marche parce que bien
évidemment les élus qui sont le corps
des grands électeurs
eh bien on voulu montrer en tout cas
qu'ils étaient reconnaissants aux
sénateurs qu'ils avaient non seulement
travailler dans leur territoire qui les
représentent et les plus fidèlement
possible
et puis il faut aussi considérer que les
annonces qui ont été faites tout au long
de l'été relative aux collectivités
territoriales ont conduit à un bilan de
l'été meurtrier et que cela a eu des
répercussions sur le score de ce soir
vous lisez une opposition renforcée à
droite une opposition donc plus forte au
chef de l'état
je ne sais pas si ça sera une opposition
plus forte
en tout cas ça sera une opposition qui
sera une opposition responsable
exigeante et utile à l'intérêt du père
et du pays et pour l'avenir des français
voilà moi je m'inscris dans cette ligne
politique au sein de mon groupe l'est
républicain et je pense que
véritablement nous aurons à montrer à
travers les républicains mais aussi avec
lui dit le centre que ce qui a fait
l'adn du sénat est toujours bien présent
le sénat toujours eu un rôle modérateur
le sénat a toujours voté des projets de
loi qui allait dans le bon sens il a
aussi amendé par des ajustements de
qualité de même projet de loi qui
d'ailleurs bon nombre d'amendements sont
conservés ou sont repris par l'assemblée
nationale
et donc c'est dans cette même ligne
politique que je pense nous nous
inscrirons pour la mandature à venir